bonsoir ravi de vous retrouver en direct
sur france 3 normandie pour vivre
ensemble cette soirée de premier tour
des élections régionales scrutin au
combien symbolique puisqu'il s'agit du
tout premier de notre normandie
réunifiée
une soirée placée sous le signe de la
proximité 1 grâce à nos cinq points de
direct installés dans tous les
départements normands et pour commenter
et analyser bien sûr ces résultats avec
nous philippe goudé bonjour bonjour
bonsoir philippe et puis chaude nuit
évidemment chaunu avec d'ores et déjà un
autre dessin un premier oui toujours
cette métaphore du débarquement le quart
des mots rares il va falloir qui prouve
qu'il est un bon pilote parce qu'il n'a
plus rien bala dans les réserves
on va voir les résultats du mois les
eskimos sur les estimations et attendait
les résultats ils commencent à nous
parvenir avant parler dans quelques
secondes
les estimations selon notre partenaire
ipsos la liste de la droite d'hervé
morin arriverait en tête avec 28 8 %
devant la liste du front national de
nicolas bay 27 2%
en troisième position la liste de
nicolas mayer rossignol pour le parti
socialiste et le prg 22 9% c'est la
statue mail pour le front de gauche 7% 6
3 % pour europe écologie les verts ee
yannick soubien nicolas calbrix unis qui
nous a rejoints sur ce plateau et qu'on
va entendre dans un instant 4%
lutte ouvrière pascal le manach 1 9%
jean-christophe l'autre upr à % et
alexandra le coeur 0 9% si la liste
nouvelle donne les estimations mais nous
avons essayé un résultat définitif frank
lowy pour le département de l'orne ça y
est la préfecture nous a communiqué ce
résultat pour l'ensemble du département
et bien c'est le front national qui
arrive en tête dans l'orne
on avait observé déjà une poussée du fn
lors des dernières départementales
municipales et européennes et bien cette
poussée se confirme ce soir puisque la
liste de nicolas bay dans l'orne
arrive en tête avec un score de 29 9%
devant la liste d'hervé morin 28,70 le
parti socialiste et la liste de nicolas
mayer rossignol est en troisième
position avec 21 91
c'est ensuite ce qui est différent par
rapport à l'estimation ipsos est bien la
liste de yannick soubien europe ecologie
les verts qui est en quatrième position
7 13
debout la france nicolas calbrix 4,96 et
le front de gauche est bien fait sont
moins bons scores dans la région dans ce
département de l'orne avec seulement 3
76% dans l'orne 1,82 paul route lutte
ouvrière 1,08 pour l'upm nouvelle bonne
0.68 toile à filer plusieurs
enseignements après tous ces chiffres à
tirer de ce premier tour dans deux
anciennes régions détenues par la gauche
votre analyse ce soir on est encore sur
des estimations alors des estimations et
ce résultat
ces mules du sondage après sondage
effectivement au cours de la soirée on
va avoir les résultats définitifs
alors ce qui est vrai c'est les filles
qu'on a pu constater depuis début la
soirée c'est que par rapport aux
sondages il ya quand même des choses qui
se précisent notamment du côté des
écologistes qui voient leurs scores
alors qu'on les a annoncé aux alentours
de 5% 4,9 y soient fusionnées 5
ils peuvent le faire donc ça c'est
important et pour le parti socialiste
j'imagine que pour les négociations qui
vont qui sont peut-être déjà qu'ils ont
peut-être déjà commencé d'ailleurs que
jamais c'est que c'est quelque chose
d'important alors le front de gauche lui
aussi on a entendu tout à l'heure madame
brulin rappeler combien sur le plan
national le front de gauche était
particulièrement critique vis-à-vis du
gouvernement et donc entend bien mener y
est chèrement une organisation aux
différentes et une fusion qui
ne peut qu avoir lieu si la gauche veut
l'emporter parce qu indéniablement le
parti socialiste a perdu beaucoup de
suffrages par rapport à 2010 mais moins
qu'annoncé par les sondages
c'est à dire que la perte est moins
importante alors monsieur quel geek
c'est sur ce plateau son résultat est
plutôt plus élevé que celui qui était
attendu et peut-être qu'on pourra leur
poser la question de savoir s'il appelle
ses électeurs ce qui veut pas dire
qu'ils vont suivre ses indications à
voter pour un accord ou pour un autre
et puis le front national effectivement
qui étant peut-être notamment la vue
dans l'orne qui fait un score important
très important même mais qu'il n'a pas
de réserve de voix pour le second tour
la question c'est de savoir si les
électeurs qui ont voté pour le front
national au premier tour vont maintenir
leur vote au 2e ou s'ils vont pas aller
dans un camp ou dans l'autre
donc c'est vrai que il peut se passer
beaucoup de choses la culture la
présentation des listes définitives
s'ils voteront froid que c'est mardi
voilà donc ça va aller très vite les
négociations peuvent peut-être durer un
certain temps cette nuit on en parlera
plus j'espère demain en tout état de
cause il ya encore beaucoup de suspense
et c'est vrai que le score
quel que soit le résultat du score du
vainqueur du chaudron du troisième la
semaine prochaine sera probablement très
serré très justement fait réagir si vous
me permettez nicolas quelles maurice qui
nous a rejoint bonsoir monsieur calbrix
vous est pour l'instant estimé 1
selon ce sondage ipsos que nous avons à
4,1 pour cent
vous estimez à 2 votre votre votre
réaction
bah tout d'abord encore une fois les
sondages entrants se sont trompés sur
notre compte puisqu'ils sont incapables
d'estimer les petites listes
c'est classique c'est habituel et c'est
malheureux pour cette fausse quand même
le jeu si on avait eu des sondages à 4
qui sait où est ce qu'on serait on l'a
fait une bonne campagne une campagne de
défendre nos valeurs gaullistes d'une
grotte gaulliste indépendante
c'était on a fait une bonne campagne les
circonstances nationales nous aussi
pénalisés on pense puisqu'on avait tout
axé sur un projet local vraiment pour la
normandie et la réunification
voilà donc maintenant on constate on
constate les résultats on voit que la
droite est certes en tête mais sans
passer la barre des 30% qui était je
pense leur objectif une forte poussée du
front national une gauche qui résiste ça
sera second tour très serré
est ce que vous appelez parce qu'on a
entendu un appel lors du premier tour il
a encore pris de décision mais le bureau
national on a un bureau national de
masse qui se réunira pour prendre la
position du second tour
est ce que vous pourriez appeler à voter
pour le front national pour l'instant
ben laden rien on n'a rien décidé on a
un bureau national demain avec nicolas
dupont aignan qui permettra tranché
notre position pour le second tour alors
ni que la non timothée ou de certaines
sainte foy du front national justement à
l'accord entre deux boules à la france
et le front national c'est quelque chose
qu'on pourra envisager
c'est ce que disait nicolas beytout
thaler dit à savoir une chose de très
positif et déjà le fait que monsieur
calbrix ne se repose pas immédiatement
un accord avec le front national est
très positif pour nous après les accords
quand ils sont passés par par les partis
ne sont pas automatiques je pense que ça
sera aussi le cas pour la gauche dans ce
second tour sans appel réel de monsieur
calbrix à voter pour le front national
je pense que nous récupérons la grande
majorité des électeurs de debout la
france pour une raison simple c'est
qu'ils ont cherché au premier tour une
alternative à l'ump au ps ils ont choisi
au premier tour la candidature de
monsieur calbrix au second tour ils ont
une alternative crédible à l'ump au ps
une alternative qui est proche de l'asie
des quais la liste menée par nicolas bay
pour le front national
et il serait assez naturel qui se
reportent vers nous vous êtes donc
courtisés monsieur calbrix on va partir
maintenant rejoindre la préfecture de
rouen où se trouve pascal martin le
président du département de seine
maritime département qui est passé à la
droite
je vous le rappelle aux dernières
départementale bonsoir monsieur martin
votre réaction ce soit encore par
rapport à nos estimations n'a pas encore
de résultat hormis pour l'orne est là
mais on voulait vous entendre sur le
sujet la première réaction c'est de
noter que la gauche est la grande
perdante de ce premier tour des
élections régionales
il faut se rappeler que les deux
exécutifs régionaux en basse normandie
haute normandie étaient tenus par des
exécutifs socialistes et aujourd'hui et
à la date ou à leurs yeux je vous parle
c'est près de 23 % uniquement porté sur
la tête du candidat socialiste c'est
quand même un élément à souligner
deuxième chose à souligner c'est que
hervé morin fait partie des candidats
portant les couleurs de la droite
républicaine et du centre qui arrive en
tête dans toutes les régions de france
et donc il y a aujourd'hui un bel espoir
de pouvoir concrétiser au soir du
deuxième tour
une victoire pour le camp que je que
j'accompagne martin on va aller à
présent rejoindre le président du
conseil départemental alain lambert
bonsoir vous avez soutenu hervé morin
jusqu'à prendre de sa défense
personnellement il y à il ya quelques
jours on annonce est justement le
résultat de l'orne avec le front
national qui arrive en tête 29 99%
votre action monsieur lambert craignons
donc c'est arrivé nous ne sommes pas le
seul département dans ce cas le front
national fait un bon score partout en
france
cela étant nous sommes aussi très
satisfait du résultat d'hervé morin et
nous sommes confiants pour le second
tour parce que nous souhaitons amplifier
encore le résultat et nous pensons que
le résultat de la gauche est un résultat
qui ne permet pas facilement de
l'emporter au second
au motif qu'il faut véritablement réunir
des personnes qui ont des points de vue
très différents sur la manière de gérer
dans la région et sur la manière de
gérer la france
justement vous avez été conseiller
régional vous connaissez bien les
affaires politiques normand qu'est ce
qui ferait la différence entre un hervé
morin à la tête de la région à nicolas
bégin nicolas mayer signale qu est ce
qui les distingue le plus
si vous deviez faire justement un un
trait de différence entre ces trois
candidats ce qui les distingue c'est que
hervé morin est porteur d'une idée de
développement économique de la région et
d'une volonté absolument de la voir
rayonner naturellement sur son propre
territoire mais en france et dans le
monde
je pense que nicolas mayer rossignol
doit être prisonnier s'il était élu par
des alliances qui le ferait mener une
politique totalement pour le mans à
rebours de ce qu'il souhaite
quand ton front national je pense que
les électeurs du front national savent
que le front national pourrait pas
l'emporter et je dois dire que leur vote
dimanche prochain sera décisif
ils ont le choix entre faire gagner la
droite et le centre ou de faire gagner
la gauche
comme j'ai le sentiment qu'ils sont plus
nombreux et espérer que la droite
l'emportent j'espère qu'ils porteront
leurs suffrages sur la liste d'armes
d'hervé morin et dans cette grande
normandie vous dit ce soir l'imaginent
jamais l'or ne sera isolé noyé dans
cette grande normandie
elle n'a jamais eu l'impression l'orne
est confiante dans son avenir et elle
pense même qu'elle était une pièce de
stabilité au sein de la normandie et
elle ne pleurniche jamais merci à la
lambert d'avoir région direction de
notre antenne merci si sûr sur les
chiffres que vous allez et merci une
soirée les chiffres que vous annoncez et
puis les réactions des uns et des autres
d'abord remercié les normands parce
qu'il s'agit de ce soir est d'or à venir
alors on est sur beaucoup de
commentaires particulièrement nationaux
mais moi je m'adresse aux normands et je
voudrais d'abord les remercier du
formidable élan d'espoir qui viennent
d'adresser en plaçant hervé morin et la
normandie conquérante en tête des
suffrages
parce que c'est eux qui sont concernés
au premier chef et on est déjà dans les
partis de la gauche
on le voit bien et avec certains de
leurs alliés pacéens qui ont conduit au
bilan des socialistes en normandie dans
des compromissions moi je dis et je
parle aux normands je leur dis continuez
à résister vous avez fait preuve d'un
grand les langues de courage et d'espoir
ce soir ayez confiance et confirmer
votre élan au deuxième tour parce que le
front national dans l'orne c'est l'échec
de laurent bouvet quand même président
sortant du conseil régional de leur
marque forcément d'abord la même c'était
de remercier les électeurs normand nous
les remercions tous on les remercie à
droite on les remercie à gauche est
normal ce sont les électeurs qui font
l'élection est pas les partis politiques
et pas les grandes déclarations
je pense qu'on est face à une situation
qui est très clair il ya trois
mouvements en ce moment
le premier c'est celui d'une dynamique
on disait nicolas mayer rossignol perdu
on voit des scores bien plus favorable
ou bien pu su bien supérieurs à ce
qu'ils étaient on voit en revanche que
l'extrême droite et la droite classique
ont enregistré des scores qui sont moins
grands que ceux qu'ils espéraient une
dynamique j'espère qu'elle va se
poursuivre la deuxième chose qui est
claire c'est le rassemblement
alors il semble difficile à la droite je
comprends la droite à peu la ville de
rassembler c'est un rassemblement autour
des valeurs
la laïcité c'est une belle valeur la
sécurité la solidarité d'égalité
c'est un rassemblement autour de projets
sur les transports vous n'en parlez pas
sur les lycées et puis en simple la
question qui sera posée à sa très claire
la personnalité du président comptera
énormément les normands besoin de
dignité et de sérieux il ya une offre de
trois paniers vous des vents normands
vont faire leurs courses un panier
pourri qui est un peu celui du front
national un panier percé qui est
malheureusement le vôtre et un panier
garni garni de projets irs ni de
compétences égales égard la cité je suis
conscient que la mairie est probablement
le président que des normands souhaite
parce que cette dignité se respectent
des normes en attendent ils l'auront
avec nicolas mas et rossignol qui je
crois a pour tous les territoires ruraux
urbains pour tous les territoires de la
basse et la haute normandie un très
grand respect et également beaucoup de
projets je crois que la question
fondamentale qui est posée pour ce
deuxième tour c'est la compétence qui
sera le mieux à même de gérer on leur
donnait la parole dans un institution
on va rejoindre le siège de france
télévisions à paris nous attend le
député républicain de l'heure et ancien
ministre de l'agriculture du
gouvernement sarkozy bonsoir bruno le
maire bonsoir vous mieux que vous
inspirent les résultats de cette
nouvelle normandie bruno le maire alors
les résultats les estimations pour
l'instant nous avons un
ça m'inspire une mobilisation totale
pour le second tour en faveur d'hervé
morin nous pouvons et nous devons gagner
la région en normandie avec hervé morin
alors nous sommes dans un mouchoir de
poche avec le front national c'est
encore indécis il reste un gros travail
à faire mais je peux vous dire que je
vais me mobiliser dès la semaine
prochaine autour d'un vrai morin je
serai lundi à caen je serai jeudi à
rouen la victoire est à portée de main
c'est une question de cohérence nous
avons regagné beaucoup de villes aux
élections municipales de 2014 notamment
dans l'eure nous avons regagné tous les
départements au début de cette année et
cinq départements de la région ont
basculé à droite
mais si nous voulons avoir une politique
qui donne des résultats qui travaillent
dans le même sens
eh bien il faut maintenant que toute la
normandie bascule du côté de la droite
et du centre avec hervé morin c'est
vraiment une question de cohérence
d'efficacité des politiques publiques au
service des normands mais comment vous
allez faire pour mobiliser en face d'une
gauche qui semble se réunir pour le coup
à nous aussi de nous rassembler encore
plus et puis surtout de mobiliser tous
ceux qui ne se seraient pas déplacés
aujourd'hui tous ceux qui ont hésité
tous ceux qui ont manifesté un mouvement
de colère
tous ceux qui ont des doutes sur la
politique de manière générale ça va être
notre rôle à hervé morin à moi-même à
tous les responsables de la droite et du
centre la semaine prochaine
et j'en appelle vraiment chaque électeur
de la droite et du centre
chaque électeur qui ne serait pas
déplacé dimanche aller aux urnes
dimanche prochain fait élire hervé morin
parce que vous aurez une région qui sera
conduite de manière cohérente avec les
départements avec les villes pour
soutenir l'emploi pour soutenir
l'apprentissage pour investir dans les
transports pour investir dans les
entreprises
l'enjeu est très important un jeu et les
régionales je ferais vraiment le maximum
pour que yahvé mort a souhaité lui
dimanche prochain merci bruno le maire
d'avoir répondu à nos questions en
direct de paris
alors bruno le maire parlait justement
d'un vote régional timothée ou sentiment
que le front national a voulu
nationaliser ce débat nationaliser cette
élection après les attentats en
récupérant le vote de ces normands alors
que l'enjeu il est historique il est la
normandie la construction de cette
grande région
je pense qu'on veut pas toujours dire à
chaque élection que malheureusement les
électeurs nationaliser le débat
si les gouvernements successifs qui soit
ump ou ps échoue on veut pas reprocher
aux électeurs de les sanctionner à
chaque fois par ailleurs nous pour ces
élections nous avons proposé un
programme très complet sur le plan
économique sur le plan des transports
sur le plan de la culture
on a aussi gagné en crédibilité pour
notre liste on présente énormément
des guides locaux en particularité en
particulier d un des élus municipaux et
puis moi aussi j'aimerais remercier
l'ensemble des électeurs qui sont
portées sur le front national en
particulier tous les nouveaux électeurs
que nous gagnons on les rencontre sur
les marchés énormément de gens qui
viennent de la droite de la gauche nous
rejoignent parce que nous représentons
une vraie alternative et nous pouvons
aussi l'emporter la semaine prochaine
puisque nous avons des réserves de voix
à la fois les électeurs notamment
d'analystes dupont aignan mais aussi
l'ensemble des abstentionnistes on a vu
une très forte mobilisation en nord pas
de calais et en paca et cette très forte
mobilisation elle s'est faite justement
pour faire gagner le front national dans
ces régions donc nous avons une
peut-être la meilleure réserve de voix
chez les abstentionnistes on va
rejoindre à salo si vous voulez bien
celui qui a été réélu ce soir conseiller
départemental du concours de villedieu
merci philippe bas d'être avec nous en
direct sur l'antenne de france 3
normandie
d'abord un mot sur votre élection on
sait que cette élection avait été
annulée pour l'histoire de bulletins de
vote qui n'étaient pas conformes qui
était de couleur en mars dernier votre
première action sur votre élection
d'abord dans votre canton
c'est la première marche pour récupérer
votre poste département c'est ça c'est
gagner l'élection de conseiller
départemental et gagner maintenant je me
soumettrai au verdict des collègues du
conseil départemental et j'espère
effectivement qu'il me renouvelle rond
vont leur confiance pour présider le
conseil départemental de la manche alors
parlons des régionales justement vous
avez combattu presque historiquement
depuis vos débuts en politique le front
national
le score du front national notamment
dans des départements ruraux dans le
département de l'orne qu'est-ce qu'il
vous inspire quel est votre réaction
je crois que pour dimanche prochain
la vraie compétition elle sera en outre
la liste d'hervé morin et la liste
socialiste est ma conviction c'est que
hervé morin va gagner et qu'il doit
gagner
hervé morin a axé toute sa campagne sur
les entreprises et l'emploi
et face à l'échec économique et sociale
de la gestion de la gauche pendant dix
ans dans nos deux régions de normandie
il me paraît absolument vital
on met un grand coup d'accélérateur sur
la politique économique
l'apprentissage l'orientation des
formations vers l'emploi et qui a une
véritable rupture par rapport à la
politique qui a été conduite pendant ces
dix dernières années dans les deux
normandie avec d'ailleurs une gestion
qui sur le plan des effectifs a été
particulièrement étonnante
on a multiplié par deux les effectifs
employés dans des administrations de ces
régions il est grand temps de remettre
de l'ordre dans le fonctionnement de ces
collectivités
on à marc antoine jamet qui est tête de
liste voilà du non socialiste ainsi et
comme que diriez vous justement à prix
bas par rapport à ce qui m'a frappé de
grandes vérités d'abord que quand on
veut la normandie il faut la voter il
faut la travailler il faut être là pour
contrairement à hervé morin décidé la
normandie sera uni la politique c'est de
la décision pour aider les gens c'est
pas simplement de l'attenté du couloir
et nicolas mas et rossignol est
quelqu'un qui s'est battu pour la
normandie existe la deuxième chose ce
n'est pas en disant que le bilan de la
région et mauvais continue la région la
main géré selon les exonérer les
contribuables associés qui n'est pas une
association de gauche
et puis la troisième chose le bilan moi
je le défends parce que c'est un bilan
qui est un bilan pour hubert meilleur
environnement plus de transport des
meilleurs lycées heureusement je les
étendre au monde et la normandie ce
débat il est bien à condition qu'on dise
des vérités le bilan est bon la
normandie est bien géré il faut le
reconnaître et le reconnaître à nicolas
mas et rossignol votre mot de conclusion
hervé morin objectivement le projet
resteront pas de son côté
c'est ce que l'on dit depuis le début de
la soirée oui elles sont à gauche c'est
pourquoi c'est pourquoi l'engagement
pour le second tour c'est vraiment vital
ça veut dire qu'au second tour il y aura
soit la victoire de la gauche qui a déjà
gouverné ces deux régions pendant dix
ans avec les résultats qu'on connaît qui
sont très mauvais sur le plan économique
et social
soit il y aura un véritable redressement
qui pourra commencer et je pense que
hervé morin et toutes ses équipes et
l'homme de ce redressement
merci monsieur va d'avoir été en duplex
avec nous depuis la préfecture de saint
lô amont portage à présent nicolas mayer
rossignol vous le savez pour l'instant
occuperait selon nos estimations la
troisième place 1
ce premier tour des élections régionales
de la normandie réunifiée nous rejoindra
bien sûr plus tard dans la soirée dès
22h15 pour participer à un grand débat
avec les autres têtes de liste
régionales mais on a souhaité aussi
passé la soirée du côté cette fois des
militants alors les militants ils ne
sont pas déçus ils ne sont pas
satisfaits il y a encore une lueur
d'espoir chez les militants on l'a vu ce
soir regardez ce reportage signé n'ya
rien libère avec olivier flavien ce sont
les journalistes qui étaient les plus
nombreux ce soir à la fédération du
parti socialiste des journalistes qu'est
la garde rapprochée de nicolas mayer
rossignol toussaint scruter leur
téléphone ou l'écran de télévision pour
connaître les premières estimations des
estimations plus optimistes pour les
socialistes que les sondages ne le
prévoyaient
on regarde le début de la campagne les
premiers sondages fait sortir début de
la campagne électorale le parti
socialiste a été nommé beaucoup moins
été nommé aujourd'hui et le front
national pareil qui chuta c'est plutôt
pour les directeurs de campagne il n'y a
pas de quoi se réjouir pour autant on
n'est pas à la fête
on est concentrés on est mobilisé de
toute façon c'est pas une campagne comme
les autres
on aime on reste quand même très marquée
par le contexte on est toujours dans une
atmosphère de dignité et de
rassemblement et puis évidemment
l'extrême droite arrive à des scores qui
est évidemment en tant que militante au
mitan de gauche nous font peur oui
jamais évidemment maintenant une belle
semaine à venir je pense c'est donc une
nouvelle campagne qui démarre ce soir
entre les tractations politiques et la
mobilisation de toutes les forces de
gauche et on va rejoindre à la
préfecture de caen dans le calvados le
président du conseil régional de basse
normandie
le socialiste laurent beauvais bonsoir
monsieur beauvais merci d'être avec nous
bonsoir la liste de nicolas mayer au
signal selon encore une fois une
estimation puisque on attend les
résultats définitifs sur la région la
synthèse régionale un peu plus tard dans
la soirée
mais la liste que vous défendiez donc
arrivé en troisième position avec selon
un réajustement il ya quelques instants
22 9% des voix en 3e position
c'est donc la liste d'hervé morin qui
arrive en tête 28 et le front national
en deuxième position 27 de votre
réaction monsieur beauvais c'est à peu
près conforme à ce que les sondages nous
indiquer voire même un peu supérieure
pour ce qui nous concerne il n'y a pas
vraiment de surprise la participation
égard est trop faible
voilà quelques premières réactions est
ce que vous attendiez un score comme
celui ci les sondages de ne vous donnez
pas forcément à 22 23 % on a vu des
sondages certains certains donneurs de
sang en dessous je vous dis que je sais
pas que ça soit une bonne surprise c'est
que c'est un score je pense qui est
conforme à ce que des tas de pignons
avait déjà était l'opinion avait été
déjà sondé il ya quelques semaines
alors on parle beaucoup de résultats
politiques on parle de résultats
nationaux même de campagne qui sait
nationalisée vous êtes à la tête de la
région depuis 2008
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment
justement qu'on a un peu oublié la
construction de la grande normandie dans
tous les débats
oui c'est évident que la campagne a été
percuté par quelques événements
extérieurs
et puis les sujets abordés pendant les
débats surtout médias compris on peut
porter sur les vrais enjeux de cette
élection régionale
que ferez vous laurent beauvais votre
avenir justement vous siègeraient à la
région c'est quelque chose qui vous
tendent
on a entendu m'a peut-être qu'en cas de
défaite de la gauche il bourg est en
mauvais se diriger vers une autre
aventure
non pourquoi mon aventure c'est la
région c'est la normandie il ya aucun
souci d'accord donc vous allez plaidé
pour justement que l'on parle davantage
de cette grande région quel programme
pour la semaine prochaine pour vous
justement comment vous allez convaincre
les électeurs
on va
leur rappeler qu'avec nos partenaires de
gauche nous avons gouverné
cette région nous avons gouverné aussi
la haute-normandie et que nous serons
tout à fait capable de poursuivre dans
cette direction les scores d'ailleurs
des uns et des autres nous donne une
avancée sensible pour ce deuxième tour
il reste maintenant avec nos partenaires
à bien définir l'essentiel de nos
orientations et comme nous avons
gouverné avec eux je suis persuadé que
nous pourrons gouverner la normandie de
demain un mot juste un mot si vous
permettez sur le score du front national
dans votre département l'orne
voyez très important il était déjà très
important avec les élections précédentes
notamment les municipales il y a deux
ans et ce score notamment dans les zones
rurales m'inquiète mais en même temps ne
me surprend pas s'il a un mauvais
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur
l'antenne de france 3 quand même un tir
dans la manche ont été justement cette
semaine puisque vous serez aux côtés de
rama yade signal pour le grand débat oui
honfleur dans second tour c'est moi mais
c'est important il est le reflet wii est
le reflet des attentes des normands dans
ce grand projet de la normandie vous
l'avez dit franck très très bien c'est
vrai que le dossier de fond a été un peu
mis sous le tapis alors que c'est la
priorité et c'est l'enjeu et moi je veux
revenir sur l'enjeu de cette grande
normandie particulièrement dans l'équipe
des territoires et je demande aux
socialistes
l'ong dont on connaît l'arrogance a
vanté un bilan toujours très très bon
alors qu'on voit bien l'échec
aujourd'hui le rejet abbaoui 29 mille
chômeurs en plus en notre nom c'est
injuste d'emplois pour les jeunes bien
sûr de formation dans la lys à beaucoup
la jeunesse c'est sûr que s'il est
important et nous verrons un résultat
définitif je voudrais qu'on parle dans
la manche parce que depuis tout à
l'heure nous nous parlons estimations
cette fois nous avons des résultats
donc on va s'y intéresser on part dans
la manche en direct oui donc que le trio
de tête à la rolls les manchois ont
placé donc en première position
hervé morin à droite et centre avec
30,23 % des suffrages exprimés en
deuxième position nicoya nicolas mayer
rossignol
parti socialiste avec 24,56 % des voix
et 3e nicolas bay le front national avec
24,54 % des voix donc très serrée avec
et socialisme est ensuite les verts ee
yannick soubien 6,93 % des voix en
cinquième position le front de gauche 5
0 1% et une école à calbrix debout la
france 5 % notons aussi bien sur les
résultats de charlesbourg qui sont
regardés de très près puisque c'est donc
le fief de bernard cazeneuve en tête
nicolas mayer rossignol le parti
socialiste 34 10% des voix
puis hervé morin 27,21 % des voix pour
la liste droite et centre est en
troisième position à cherbourg le front
national avec 18,80 qu'au 15 % des
suffrages
extrait voici les résultats définitifs
de la manche garcia m'a dit cela va-t-il
se tait on rappelle également donc la
réélection de philippe bach canton de
villedieu la présidence du département
de la manche
résultat dans l'eure à présent on
retrouve frédéric nicolas oui
effectivement franck est la tendance
dont on parlait tout à l'heure c'est
confirmé puisque c'est la liste du front
national qui est en tête avec 33 58% des
suffrages exprimés suivi par hervé morin
qui était tête de liste dans ce
département 28,37 % le parti socialiste
nicolas mayer rossignol marc antoine
jamet 20,28 % suivent derrière sébastien
jumel pour le front de gauche c'était
monsieur le comte un ancien maire de
vernon qui était ancien adjoint de
vernon qui étaient sur cette liste puis
les écologistes et yannick soubien 5 26%
et les autres scores vous les voyez que
les autres listes de vous la france 3,8
pour cent des scores plus petit pour les
trois dernières l'iss en attendant les
résultats de quelques villes notamment
gisors je tiens à vous signaler ce
résultat le front national fait un très
bon score là bas également +2 35% et la
liste du front de gauche arrive en
quatrième position 13 0 2% elle talonne
le parti socialiste qui est troisième à
13,35 % merci frédéric on part dans
l'orne à la préfecture d'alençon où là
aussi les résultats définitifs
on était confirmé il ya quelques
instants nicolas corbas arrêté alençon
oui en effet on a les résultats
définitifs les résultats de vous avez
communiqué tout à l'heure ne comprenait
pas toutes les voies d'alençon alors le
front national arrive bien en tête avec
29,02 4% des voix la liste d'hervé morin
juste derrière et à 28,34 % et la liste
de gauche menée dans l'ordre par laurent
beauvais aucune 23 05 % des suffrages
europe écologie les verts dans la tête
de liste régionale l orne et yannick
soubien est à 7 24% des voix sans
surprise les ville d'alençon argentan et
flers largement à voter socialiste
mais argentan et à fléron trouve juste
derrière le front national à 24% des
voix
la surprise c'est donc le front national
en tête dans l'orne et particulièrement
dans les petites communes rurales de
l'est du département la commune qui a
voté en masse front national ces vies
des 78 habitants à la limite de la
sarthe et du perche
les habitants ont voté à 65 % pour le
front national
alors ce n'est pas vraiment surprenant
lors de la présidentielle de 2012 marine
le pen était monté jusqu'à 50% dans ces
petits êtres commune puis c'est
peut-être pour ses villages un moyen
d'exprimer leurs craintes d'être noyé
dans cette grande région l'est du
département est particulièrement touchée
par le chômage le vieillissement de la
population et la crainte de voir
disparaître les services publics de
proximité comme c'est le cas à l'aigle
ou certains services du centre
hospitalier sont menacés en tout cas
c'est aussi une déconvenue pour les
socialistes arrivé troisième et qui
dispose tout de même d'une réserve de
voix importantes en vue du second tour
merci nicolas on va c'est justement au
score du front national qui fait plus
que doubler son score par rapport aux
dernières régionales de 2010
nicolas bay en l'entendue lors de notre
première partie d'émission de soirée
tout à l'heure à 20h15 croit en salle à
sa victoire on en débattra tout à
l'heure avec lui avec les autres têtes
de liste de six régional sur ce plateau
voyez ce reportage d'abord de damien
mignot et jean michel guillot
il n'est pas encore 20 heures est
l'ambiance au sein de la permanence à
caen est plutôt terne
peut-être que la quarantaine de
militants et de sympathisants présents
attendent de voir pour y croire vraiment
le suspense ne sera pas bien long
clameur renouveler à chaque fois que le
parti de marine le pen arrive en tête
dans six régions au total quant à la
normandie elle est certes un cran en
dessous
nicolas bay est en deuxième position il
n'empêche tous ces résultats sont
exceptionnels
c'est un dimanche historique pour les
résultats nationaux national ont dépassé
les scores prévu ont fait nettement
mieux qu'en 2010 ne serait ce même dans
normandie on était à 8 10% je crois en
normandie alors on attendait pas et 7%
c'est inespéré content certainement le
fn désormais fait jeu égal bien qu'en
normandie une victoire frontiste ou
second tour ne semble pas un rêve cette
fois encore accessible honnêtement je
pense que ça sera difficile mais plus on
sera plus on aura de lui je ne sais pas
si on sera en tête malgré tout certains
voulaient effectivement que nous être
favorable de toute façon dans le sens où
on a encore le temps cette semaine de
convaincre les électeurs qui se sont
abstenus de voter aujourd'hui voilà
ambiance ce soir avec les militants de
nicolas bay à caen jean luc lecomte de
tête de liste du front de gauche
votre action sur la poussée de ce front
national justement est ce que c'est
quelque chose qui vous inquiète
même s'il arrive en troisième position
bien sûr le front national fait beaucoup
trop et je vais en parler par rapport à
demain à ce soir et à demain d'abord
quand même le front de gauche conforte
ses positions et je crois que les
derniers résultats qui tombent renforce
les positions de sébastien jumel
et la liste du front de gauche alors
juste ce que je veux et internet vous
mêlez toujours toujours je viens quand
même parler de l'extrême moi parce que
je veux dire quand même que nous sommes
nous viscéralement anti extrême droite
que nous voulons faire barrage à la
droite et que c'est le sens du
rassemblement des forces du front de
gauche où les communistes pour une place
déterminante est il des écologistes
je voudrais quand même dire deux mots
sur ce rassemblement parce que c'est le
salon le débat sur votre score selon
l'estimation en accord là on attendait
les résultats définitifs
on en a déjà quelques uns par ville et
par département
le front de gauche selon ipsos est
classé en quatrième position avec un
score de 7 %
que dites vous puisque vous parlez d'un
rassemblement très concrètement est ce
que vous appelez à une alliance avec le
parti social et jeux marc antoine jamet
qui est à côté de jouer je me souviens
bien sa passion il ne serait pas juste
non mais je suis impatient de répondre à
cette question et ça va être très clair
car mettez moi quand même de développer
un tout petit peu je crois qu'il ya un
élément politique nouveau qui n'a
échappé à personne ici c'est que ce
n'était pas le cas en 2010 aujourd'hui
la majorité la gauche ne peut pas gagner
sans le front de gauche et sa composante
importante quel parti communiste et sans
les écologistes
je veux dire sur le rassemblement il
s'agit bien d'un rassemblement pour
faire barrage à la droite et à l'extrême
droite et je crois que ce que j'ai envie
d'exprimer avec le plus de force ici
c'est que les électeurs les électrices
nous ont donné le mandat de ne rien
lâcher d'ici le second tour accompli je
veux non non je veux dire par là vous
aviez que nous faisons avec le parti non
non non et non
égouttez souvent non mais c'est pas ça
du tout sébastien jumel a l'habitude de
dire c'est fini les négociations la pape
et je voudrais un petit peu illustré
sein la question elle n'est pas
effectivement de mener des négociations
sur un coin de table et de discuter de
la part des uns et des autres alors on
voit maintenant que vous le permettez
non gardé
les nerds qui était bas après l'orne et
et la manche je voudrais qu'on parle
dans dans leur s'il vous plaît je
voudrais qu'on s'arme dans l'eure je
voudrais qu'on s'intéresse au
département de l'eure très rapidement
parce que on rejoint sébastien lecornu
qui en direct avec nous depuis le siège
de france télévisions à paris bonsoir
monsieur le corps nu dans un département
qui je vous le rappelle a basculé à
droite aux dernières départementale que
vous inspire ce soir la place d'hervé
morin qui militait 1 depuis 99 à la
réunification de cette normandie présent
à la région depuis 2004
dites-nous bas-côté bonsoir bonsoir moi
ce que je vois c'est que dimanche
prochain nous pouvons gagner la liste
menée par les morin peut engager
l'alternance dont la grande normandie a
besoin on voit bien que ça se joue entre
la liste du parti socialiste et la liste
d'hervé morin une voix pour le front
national c'est malheureusement une voix
pour le parti socialiste
on doit gagner dimanche prochain alors
vous devez gagner en même temps je
rectifie avec des résultats définitifs 1
7 fois dans leur nicolas bay est devant
avec 33 points 58 % devant hervé morin à
28 37 % et nicolas mayer rossignol
arrive en troisième position à 20,28 %
comment allez vous mobiliser justement
écoutez il faut mobiliser en expliquant
aux électeurs
nos propositions votre programme le
bilan également de la gauche dans ces
régions rappelez vous il ya un an disait
que le département de l'eure était le
département potentiellement le mieux
gérées de france et on s'aperçoit depuis
de nombreuses semaines audit après audit
vérité après vérité que tout cela
n'était que mensonge
et bien aujourd'hui on nous dit que la
région normandie une région bien géré et
bien malheureusement on sait ce que vaut
la parole des socialistes en la matière
donc il faut faire la vérité sur le
bilan la vérité sur nos propositions
faire de la pédagogie expliquer à la
ruralité
l'enjeu de cette grande région normandie
puisqu'on le voit bien les villes ont
placé la liste d'un mémo rhin en tête on
voit bien que dans la ruralité
il ya un sujet avec le front national il
y un sujet d'abandon il faut aller à la
rencontre de ces françaises de ces
français là de ces normands la merci
beaucoup sébastien lecornu d'avoir réagi
on va aller si vous voulez jean léonce
dupont qui nous attend
à la préfecture du calvados le président
du département udi proche d'hervé morin
bonsoir monsieur dupont on voit qu'il ya
des morins arrive en tête selon ce
baromètre cette estimation ipsos on
attend encore une fois les résultats
définitifs cette synthèse régionale mais
il est devancé dans certains
départements comme le département de
l'orne comme le département de l'eure
croyez vous encore en la victoire la
semaine prochaine écoutez dans le
département du calvados hervé morin
arrive à pratiquement 31% très nettement
en tête et nous avons bon espoir pour
qu'effectivement ce soit la même chose
dans tous les départements
comment allez vous prendre par l'accord
à la campagne justement on vous a assez
peu vu jean léonce dupont 2 dans cette
campagne aux côtés d'hervé morin ainsi à
chaque réunion de meetings comme il le
fait quand il le fallait dans le
département je voudrais en tout cas en
particulier expliqué ou calvadosien mais
à l'ensemble des normes en que l'équipe
qui doit gagner et celle qui a la vision
la plus équilibrée de l'ensemble des
territoires celle où on est tous gagnant
gagnant et pas celles qui présentent des
schémas où tout va à un endroit et pas
un autre
oui la préfecture et à rouen et c'est
tout à fait bien mais le siège doit être
accordée effectivement être
effectivement à caen
c'est la condition effectivement de cet
équilibre et de la réussite de
l'ensemble
imaginez effectivement une assemblée qui
s'est réunit quatre fois par an à caen
et le président l'ensemble des bureaux
des directions qui se retrouvent à rouen
à côté de la préfecture
basé sur l'axé seine avec la force
naturelle est reconnu de l'axé seine
ce serait une catastrophe une
catastrophe pour l'ensemble car il n'y
aurait pas d' équilibre il y aurait des
parties de territoire qui se sentiraient
complètement complètement abandonné
merci nous sommes pour l' équilibre
hervé morin s'est dès le départ le
premier est pratiquement le sol
positionner clairement sur ce sujet
écoutez encore ce soir les propos du
maire de rouen et vous verrez bien que
beaucoup restent encore dans l'ambiguïté
il n'y a pas d'hésitation il faut voter
pour hervé morin merci tendu pour
justement puisque nous partons pour moi
si vous le permettez recueillir la
réaction cette fois de celle qui fut
maire et
istres également du gouvernement héros
bon soir valérie fourneyron
on ne vous a pas entendu votre réaction
par rapport au résultat j'ajoute que sur
la ville de rouen nicolas mayer
rossignol arrive en tête 32 51 % des
voix nicolas mayer rossignol en tête sur
rouen j'imagine votre satisfaction oui
une satisfaction de voir nicolas mayer
rossignol effectivement avec un très bon
score puisqu'il est supérieur aux
derniers résultats sur les
départementales et sur les municipales à
rouen donc un bon résultat mais
globalement sur la normandie on nous
prédisait une large défaite ce soir
nicolas mayer rossignol avec l'ensemble
des 10 sur les cinq départements fait un
résultat tout ça tout à fait
satisfaisant et avec un rassemblement
avec une mobilisation large de gauche au
deuxième tour nous pouvons l'emporter
je crois que sur le terrain et on l'a vu
pendant cette campagne moi j'ai été très
présente et on a vu combien le discours
de nicolas mayer rossignol son
efficacité son sa connaissance de
l'ensemble des territoires travailleurs
pragmatique responsables croient que on
ne s'y est pas trompé et aujourd'hui moi
j'appelle à ce que cette mobilisation
elle soit encore plus large au deuxième
tour pour qu'il puisse se traduire dans
les urnes cette vision qu'il a pour la
normandie
merci madame heures et on a va réagir en
direct depuis à 2 euros
comment les internautes les politiques
ont-ils vécu cette grande soirée les
régionales on va retrouver aurélie
misery qui suit tout ce qui se passe sur
le web rebond soir aurait lui quels sont
les commentaires les tweets
mais à côté les réseaux sociaux étaient
très actifs à 20h15 au tour au moment
des premiers résultats mais là c'est
beaucoup plus calme
bien sûr les réactions ce qui domine ce
pour les réactions c'est le score du
front national avec des réactions très
contrastées
les partisans qui appelle à soutenir
nicolas bay on ne lâchera rien badasa si
tu as un tweet d'une dune internautes
en revanche d'autres appellent à faire
barrage
comme cet internaute qui s'adresse aux
électeurs de yannick soubien de
sébastien jumel
ensemble avec nicolas mayer rossignol
faisons gagner des forces de progrès
dimanche alors en parler
taux de participation un tweet en forme
de clin d'oeil cet internaute qui n'a
pas pu voter elle a attendu deux heures
pour faire sa procuration mais sa
procuration n'est pas arrivé il y aurait
donc des réserves de voix voilà et vous
pouvez toujours nos cieux sur notre site
internet
merci beaucoup auraient liseré d'avoir
fait le point pour nous sur les tweets
justement on va analyser avec vous si
vous le permettez philippe boudé les
résultats définitifs cette fois que nous
avons récupéré philippe avant de se
quitter et de se retrouver un tout petit
peu plus tard dans la soirée
on a aujourd'hui la manche l'eure et
l'orne alors alors avec soin le front
national on fait ça c'est une réalité
et si vous prenez également les
résultats dans les villes on s'aperçoit
que c'est souvent monsieur morin qui est
en tête avec ses listes mais il n'a pas
de réserve de voix pas beaucoup de
regards derepas plus aller au front
national et du côté de la gauche il y a
des réserves de voix à conditions on a
entendu tout à l'heure monsieur le comte
précisé que les négociations allaient
aller difficile longue et peut-être un
petit peu abîmés l'ont fait parce que si
on donne à part cela je l'attendrai à se
parler j'ouvre la série policière pour
lesquelles les gens devraient donc en
fait le deuxième tour commence dès ce
soir avec l'organisation avec
l'organisation générale levadas débat
qui s'annonce quand même aligné à gauche
alors intéressant vient de rejoindre ou
bien tête de liste le gilet vert vous
avez quelques secondes simplement pour
réagir à ces résultats
alors écoutez vous dire que dans la
diffusion puisque monsieur le comte
parler de ce rassemblement de l'italie
de rassemblement la non-diffusion
collègues va devoir apprendre à nous et
c'est un tout petit peu la parole si
effectivement on doit faire connaissance
et porter ensemble un projet moi je
voulais vous dire que d'abord ce premier
tour a été un 1er tour de grande qualité
pour nous les écologistes nous avons
porté les fondamentaux d'écologie
politique la transition écologique
nous avons réussi à faire en sorte que
tout ça rassemble y compris des citoyens
je crois que c'est ça qu'il s'agit
d'expliquer aux citoyens et ceux qui
sont électeurs aujourd'hui le taux
d'abstention est trop important le vote
du front national c'est une catastrophe
donc soyons un peu serein et donnons un
peu de hauteur au débat
bien évidemment que nous allons
maintenant nous avons vocation à faire
alliance nous allons nous discuter nous
allons d'abord parler d'un accord
programmatique la transition écologique
sera au coeur de les changes que nous
aurons tous ensemble
sophie gaugain a terminé me je crois que
la normandie mérite mieux que des
alliances et des accords nous avons un
projet clair serein est ce que je
voudrais dire aux normands c'est que
depuis 10 ans et 11 ans
il a excusé moi est ce que vous
confirmez en parler on va les retire
mais en parler on n'a pas de choix même
boga ans 22h15 en barque sur la
nationale
à tout à l'heure
m